this right here okay with
uh what happened on
uh your your argument you're making in
this topic specifically on what happened
on 9 11 can you just take a
moment and present what your argument is
and how you came to this conclusion
yeah
well when
when i was confronted with this elderly
gentleman in 2006
he talked about a third tower that came
down
i mean
i'm an architect i would know if there
was a skyscraper that came down on
911
that wasn't hit by a plane
i mean this is a 47-story skyscraper
easily the tallest building in most of
our states
but at 5 20 in the afternoon
after witnesses hear explosions
this building drops like a rock
straight down uniformly symmetrically
into its own footprint
in under seven seconds
that's at free fall acceleration that's
as fast as a bowling ball falling out of
the sky
and we didn't know about it most
architects and engineers don't know
about it
we in i'm one of 90 000 members of the
american institute of architects there
wasn't one bulletin issued
on
this
major structural collapse and no plane
hit it so it had a few small fires and
according to nist the national institute
of standards and technology who was
tasked by congress to explain these
collapses to the american people
they say these fires brought the
building down wait a minute
normal office fires have never brought
down
a steel frame
fire protected
skyscraper
ever in history and there's been dozens
and dozens and dozens
of much hotter larger and longer lasting
fires in these buildings and we haven't
lost one so this is an unprecedented
event it should have been the most
studied building failure ever
and sure enough nist produces a thousand
pages of obfuscation
and this elaborate
fairy tale of the initiation of collapse
in this building
none of the components
of which could actually have happened
they had to eliminate
key structural
components in the building in order to
try to fabricate uh a plausible
collapse initiation theory for instance
they say that
the
the the beams heated up
in in in an extraordinary fashion 1400
degrees fahrenheit well that couldn't
happen because they're fireproofed and
in this case there's no plane to knock
off the fireproofing like they claimed
at the twin towers well uh
okay let's let's just say that those
beams could have expanded because they
said this is thermal expansion which
caused a girder to be pushed off of its
seat
on this column 79 in the building well
the girder couldn't have slid
sideways because there are shear studs
tying it very carefully and these are in
the shop drawing so nist it just says
they weren't there
so the girder let's say that it could
have slid off of its seat and then uh it
would have had to have slid 12 inches
off of its seat because that's the size
of the seat and this says no it only had
to
slide halfway off and then the flange
folded and then it came down well the
flange couldn't have folded because
there are structural stiffeners welded
on to keep that flange from folding and
the web from crippling
and but they ignored those three quarter
inch thick welded steel stiffeners
completely ignored them uh said they
weren't
needed in the analysis so but let's say
that girder could have
uh fallen uh off of its seat on column
79 you wouldn't have had the third the
13th floor falling on the 12th because
the 13th floor didn't have enough well
there's two other major girders framing
into that particular column
so you couldn't have had it falling at
all but let's say it could have it
didn't have enough force though a
dynamic force to
break the connections of the girder on
the 12th floor below
so
but let's say that did happen and like
nist claims that there's this cascading
collapse on the east side of the
building
uh and and but then you would have they
say this lateral instability traveled
across this
building which is as long as a football
field
uh in just six seven seconds
it's it's absolutely ridiculous because
this that would mean 400 structural
steel connections would have had to have
failed
all
uh within every second and along that
way but let's say that could have
happened they're saying the interior
collapsed and then followed
six seconds later by
or so by the exterior
well
that couldn't have happened either
because we can all see that the
penthouse structures the west penthouse
and screen wall fall just a half a
second prior to the overall collapse
well the those structures sit on the
remaining core columns 20 of them
uh after the east penthouse collapses
which is an isolated event so those 20
columns had to have given way all at
once a half a second prior to the
overall collapse of this building
completely also just proving their
theory
so
we know that uh
as
professor leroy hulsey found out
one of the top friends structural
engineers in the country at the
university of alaska at fairbanks was
took on the job a four-year study of
this incredible
uh collapse he said we got to know if
this is true no plane hit this building
no no skyscrapers ever come down due to
fire before uh steel frame fire
protected uh skyscrapers and so we got
to find out what happened here
so um he did and guess what he concluded
that this building did not come down by
fire it could not have collapsed even if
the three columns that it claims were in
turn
uh buckling uh the building would have
tipped over which is intuitive for all
of us
so he also found out
and concluded that
the building uh came down because all of
its columns were removed
and removed within a second of each
other the interior followed by the
exterior completely confirming
what the video analysis shows us
so this is an incredible corroboration
of what we already know about building
seven just looking at the videos but
also hearing the
uh
the witnesses who heard explosions now
this is all on our our website
richardgage911.org
witnesses a half a dozen of them heard
and are testifying to explosions before
the building comes down and then we look
in the dust
the concrete powder that's throughout
world trade center and we find lots of
evidence
additionally confirming
the use of incendiaries in this building
we'll get into that so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]